hello everyone and welcome back to the
2018 st. Louis blitz and rapid
tournament this is the penultimate round
of the blitz section so day five of the
tournament I'd shag our mama the era of
versus Hikaru Nakamura now a very
interesting event as you all seen how
strong mommy Dro is lately he won the
2018 bill chess festival and he's really
been performing well here but he is up
against eco Nakamura who has been known
to be one of the greatest speed chess
players in the world
so before we check it out we do have a
nice photo challenge so hope you are
ready for it who is the gentleman in the
photo next to the chess board so there
we have it
best of luck to everyone now we also
have a nice photo of this game there you
have it Nakamura on the right mama deriv
on the left and also Nakamura
redbull on the right I've also noticed
that Nakamura as of lately opens his red
bull but I've never actually seen him
drink some of it so once again it would
definitely improve the marketing for red
bull if he would sometime at least take
a sip from it or at least you know pour
water in it and drink water from the
bottle but yeah that being said let's
check out the game mamita has the white
piece and it's really an incredible
fighting game with a lot of a lot of
hidden ideas mama door opens with Knight
to f3 the reti opening night to have six
c4 e6 so transposing into the English
III d5 b3 and Bishop to e7 Bishop to b2
D captures on c4 b captures on c4 and
now c5 Knight to c3 b6 prepare preparing
to develop the light square bishop and
here my media goes 4G for a standard
idea in similar openings where white
hopes to sacrifice in the g4 pawn if
black doesn't react of course g5 is
coming but if you capture then rook to
g1 is coming and perhaps it is playable
for black button I don't think anyone
would allow this would black because the
g7 pawn would come under attack and then
you have to play something like this and
then I mean you don't want to play
something like this
so after g4 we have Bishop to b7
Nakamura keeps developing nicely pinning
this night as the rook is on h1 and
we have g5 937 and h4 now protecting the
g5 porn and here are wonderful move
Knight to e5 getting ready to do some
exchanges because as we've said the
knight on f3 is pinned but is it really
here mama care of sacrifices the
exchange knife captures on e5 Bishop
captures on h1 and here comes Queen to
a4 check it's a very peculiar position
as it is a blitz game so I doubt he car
or mommy I've ever had this position on
the board to like analyze it here it
seems that the best idea is actually
Queen to h5 not Queen to H equal to a
four with the threat of of course Queen
captures on f7 checkmate and after you
defend this Queen to g4 is coming and
it's it's a nice position for white
after white black continues developing
you have this Knight to d5 move a very
nice tactical shot you block this
bishops defense of the night here Knight
captures here is a threat you open up
this diagonal from the bishop to the
rook so a very complicated position can
arise here but you know it's impossible
to see everything in blitz so Bushell
captures we have Queen to f4 check
Knight blocks and now f3 as the knight
and e5 is guarding the f3 pawn a mom
Dara would very much enjoy capturing
this bishop on h1 at some point in the
game b5 a very nice move by Nakamura the
the idea is if Queen captures then you
get rook to b8 attacking the Queen and
the bishop here and now what doesn't
really have a choice you have to capture
here and after Queen captures Knight
captures and here King captures leaving
leaving this idea for the moment here so
after Knight a for defending bunch of
characters on f3 and always will here
for black
so after this beef I move we have Knight
captures here and although it seems this
Knight can't move because Knight to c7
is a terrible threat nakamura actually
plays this he plays Knight captures on
e5 and some here for some reason
momager played Bishop captures on e5 he
doesn't go for night night to c7 check
with a double check against the king
there is no other thing to do here then
King to f8 &
he saw here that after after night
captures rook then the bishop can come
back into the game or Knight captures
and if three would even be an idea but
simply Bishop captures on e5 you grab a
knight you protect the night here the
rook is still under attack and I have
two rogue defense Queens e6 everything
is guarded the Queen is guarding the f3
pawn so always well here but of course
this is this is blitz you can see
everything so here instead of this
Knight c7 a double check Bishop captures
an e5 by mom and Europe and here we have
castles you can't leave the King there
for for her for a bit more because here
if you try and you know get this special
back into the game you'll get Bishop
captures on g7 and after rook moves you
get an ID six and this is checkmate as
the bishop is now guarding the f8 square
and it's a double check from the Queen
and the night so a lot of problems here
so after castles we have Bishop to e2
now guarding the f3 pawn f6 we have
queenside castle and the bishop to g2
now as it is attacked on h1 rogue g1 and
the bishop to h3 and here we have Bishop
day 1 getting the bishop out of the way
ie 5 and now Knight back to c3 Bishop to
e6 Queen to c6 attacking the bishop on
e6 and now Queen to c8 offering a trade
of Queens and now another beautiful
attacking idea by Mohammed er of Knights
to d5 the idea of course is if Queen
captures Queen then Knight captures
Bishop on e7 with check King moves
Knight captures here and white would be
up a dark square Bishop
so after this Knight to d5 move we have
Bishop to d8 and getting the bishop out
of the way and now mama Jarvis is very
happy to exchange Queen captures rook
captures and pawn captures on f6 Bishop
captures Knight captures rook captures
and now comes the Bishop captures on e5
rook to f7 and now f4 Nakamura is up the
exchange but mamedyarov
has a nice bishop pair and also the
pressure and the G file is more than
enough to compensate for for the
exchange
rook to c6 we have King Tubby to now
comes rogue d7 Bushra back to c3
guarding the d2 pawn bishop to f5 with
some nice threats
the bishop covers b1 so rock here to
here could be very annoying at some
point h5 preparing to push h6 or simply
not allowing g6 room b6 check and king
to a-1 at some point during the live
feed I was watching this game live and
the commentators Yasser and Jen and
mentioned at some point that it's very
unfortunate that you have to put the
king to a-1 and you know the king will
be completely cut off but you don't have
any other options here if King c1 Ruby
one is checkmate and it's a very nice
idea if you go King a3 just a nice you
know tactical shot feel free to pause
the video here and find this beautiful
mating idea so feel free to do it I will
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who have founded congratulations
you are an excellent supporter of
tactical shots and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show rook db7 a
simple idea that simply there is no way
to prevent rook to a sex checkmate so I
mean there is but you have to you know
suffer severe loss of material for
example rook captures rook captures and
then it would just be unplayable a rook
and Bishop against the bishop so yeah
after this rook to b6 check King to a-1
now the king is cut off but okay King f8
Bishop to g4 Bishop captures rook
captures into now h6 not allowing white
to push h6 a3 making some room for the
king rugby 7 and now route back to g1
and not allowing rugby 1 check we have
rook to e6 Bishop to e5 and the now
comes rook to d7 rook to g2 defending
the d2 pawn and now Luke goes back to b7
King to a - and now rook to d7 white is
still better here but in a blitz game
it's it's not always that easy to find
the correct plan
king bee three we have rugby 7 check
King c2 and the rook to a6
going for the a3 pawn and Russia back to
be to simply defending it rook a to b6
attacking the bishop bishop to c1 and
now rook the b1 we have rope to g6
rook to e1 preparing the other rook to
come to be 1
d for now look to eat to check and this
is the critical moment of the game but I
will I will show you how the game went
on for a couple of moves and then we're
gonna return so you will be able to
understand better why this is the
critical moment of the game here King 2
D 3 was played and this is the losing
move of the game
Roop could be one attacking the bishop
we have Ruby G 1 defending and now comes
Rock the B 3 check and now this is the
problem
King e4 and rook the c2 now attacking
the bishop there is no square for the
bishop to go to there's no move white
can play here ma media of played D
captures on c5 and here simply rook to
be won and now the bishop has no squares
left if you move it you can even lose
the rook on g1
so King if I was playing but now simply
rook captures and c1 was played and it
was in this position that shocked their
mama dr of resigned at the game even
though he played a wonderful game and
was better for most most of the game
there was nothing to do but why i say
rook a to check was the critical moment
in the game is because here mama dr went
king to d3 had he gone kink to c3 there
is no problem because now the same
variation doesn't apply there is no
rugby 1 attacking the bishop robbed g1
and now there is no rugby 3 check to
kick the king all the way here to trap
the bishop because from c3 the king is
covering the be 3 square but you know in
the in this you know
in this struggle with with the speed and
everything there was just no way to see
that this would be the critical moment
of the game
I mean someone checks you you want to
get your king between the pawns to
safety as possible start pushing your
you're deep on but yeah unfortunately a
very nice a very nice game for Hikaru
Nakamura so as I said this was the
penultimate round and it was here that
Nakamura already won the tournament even
though he lost his game in the final
round so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and that you've enjoyed
this very very short coverage of the st.
Louis reputable it's tournament and we
do have a couple of more interesting
statistic photos here also there you
have it Gaara Nakamura he won the rapid
and blitz in st. Louis he won thirty
seven thousand and five hundred dollars
one thirteen two points so he has a
position first here we have these are
the final standings of the combine
Blitzen rapid and Nakamura in first
place 22 and a half maxime beaugeois
graphic or one or twenty our onion and
with 18 Sergei kurakin linear Dominguez
Alexander grease Chuck Wesley so and
Vishwanathan Anand in last place for
example as you can see Wesley so in 9th
place here in st. Lewis rapid and
weights but he did have a couple of
great events during the Grantchester
so in this total Grantchester 2018
overall you can see that Wesley so is
actually in fourth place
so Nakamura for this is these are the
standings of the grand chest or total
it's currently in first place with 33
points so well not it will not be easy
to catch up to him but you know anything
can happen he so far $90,000 for for the
first price of the Grantchester
then Maxine Sergey Kirk in Wesley
Sullivan Ariane momiji are in sixth
grade again 7th
Fabiana karana in eighth and Vishwanath
on in ninth yeah a lot of interesting
things to you know to discover here so I
do hope you enjoyed that as well I would
like to thank ingenious and Hector
Coronado for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate
as usual you can check to my previous
video Sierra thank y'all for watching
and I will see you soon with another
game from the Bobby Fischer series Game
six Fisher versus diamond off thank you
all and I'll see you soon